[Applause]
okay excuse me miss I gotta I gotta
commandeer this vehicle all right you'll
have to get out y'all gotta get out
y'all
I'm sorry look but look FBI FBI FBI but
y'all got to get out of vehicle what is
the situation
okay okay okay well let me just okay you
don't need to know D all the details the
situation let me just put a hypothetical
to you no okay all right hypothetically
there was the dude okay
and perhaps that dude was in the middle
of robbing a liquor store right and
maybe he found the safe it was like wow
finally jackpot six liquor stores
couldn't find the safe finally found a
safe braving the grinders safe and to do
was cooperative and he got the money
right and now that dude is fleeing the
scene that is not an FBI situation
that's a police okay let me take this
one off your hands
well you know what I'm gonna say thank
you for the tip right right so that we
can do our job
no no no it's real good I mentioned this
did I mention this about said gentlemen
okay I don't know if I had mentioned
this he is from he's from Kenya okay
international okay all right
he's a Kenyan refugee all right he's
gonna take that money and turn it into
Kenyan notes and go back to Kenya and
take a bunch of little babies and bring
them back here and sell him okay I can't
have that you know what I'm gonna let
you come I'm gonna let you come in dear
this vehicle I love it but in the back
seat okay all right that's fine and I'ma
tell you what is you can come down to
the station with us
I will tell us Oh now are we gonna be
stationed how about we get as close to
the state line as we possibly can I'm
gonna say why don't you give me that
again what take a look at okay all right
that's man but I believe I still have
jurisdiction over you as a member of
Department of the Treasury
okay yes thank the Lord
okay hey baby what's going on Bravo
thank you so much for coming so here's
what I want to say y'all understand
right now right off the top I called you
to report a crime
that I don't have nothing to do with
okay oh this is a first I'm not involved
in the crime I didn't perpetrate the
crime I didn't do anything okay I was
yes ma'am yes we can I was meinem oh I
was walking down the street ok and I was
indeed I'm not gonna lie I'm a vagabond
a bit I'm a little bit of a bag about I
was looking for shelter I found this
vehicle the window was open and I
climbed it I climb I looked in the trunk
and there's something in the trunk that
I think may be of interest to you so I
made sure that I called immediately
what's in the trunk there's a head
there's a head in the trunk
there's a head 23 year-old male head
hypothetically if I had what would the
questions be hypothetically I just was
not me okay I hate you Jerome why did
you betray me
why did you mother we're not real
playing anymore playing real-life why'd
you say Jerome that's my cousin's name
had just come to me right now is your
cousin living areas alive he's alive
with the Lord alive with the Lord get
your ass in the car
hypothetically speaking you're about to
get your salad tossed in prison oh okay
well thank God is hypothetical
I figure if they call it Superman Excel
that's gonna make you some Excel right
it's like I don't know what it is done
do Pat me down right now
packing it right now me down right now
what real do this man
what happened me down how do you doubt
right now to do with me why do I gotta
like there's some about this I don't
like I'm gonna take my hands on my
pocket right real real slow real slow
all right okay y'all understand okay now
look here now I wanted to ask you both a
question
all right about the contents of my
pockets okay our first question was
gonna be do you have any illicit sex in
your pocket sudden this is like jeopardy
where the question gets put to us and
and we have what the help now I'll take
those down ceremony I'll put my hands
back in my pocket no this time now let's
keep them up oversized okay okay let me
just set up a scenario for you okay
Kushina setting an example he's gonna
tell something yeah a gentleman was
careening down the streets okay and
bumped into me very quickly
now listen man I don't know if y'all
believe in God but I believe in God
okay and I'm gonna tell you what
happened every one of them bottles have
blown up into the air and it had flown
into my pockets and that was God knowing
that I was having I was feeling a little
down you know blue last week okay and he
provided you with five hours not long so
the Lord provided for me hey you wanna
throw those on for me okay thank you
yeah that'd be great
oh you'll have oh you took home one and
ones both take half oh I'll Drive we are
play Montreux I'd be more than happy to
drive good
okay excuse me officer okay I just need
to tell you right now all right that
this is not what it looks like I came
here to ask you a couple of questions
well go ahead okay believe make-believe
right make-believe if one would you come
across a wheelbarrow like this okay and
this wheelbarrow may have been involved
in some kind of illicit activity that
may involve two or three people wearing
masks and one of them may happen to work
at the Metro casino no that's not a here
nor day I came diligently looking for
you
thank God I won't touch officer but I
wouldn't care if I could I would hug you
looking for you just to show you that
this could indeed be contraband
involving people and if it ask you this
if indeed this was contraband yes and if
we're involving people yes all of the
people involved would they all get in
trouble yes that's what they're born to
do windows don't roll down back here let
me get that muskrat muskrat is that
damned you've done this before I think I
might have there might be some subtle
hints of elk uh you should join the
carnival boy you got time so talk in the
truck you got too much grass 2-month
grand old leave her and I think it used
to be possum but also I can't tell no no
no there's a little bit of possum and I
can smell the possum just to touch a
touch of possum playful but Roebuck yeah
I'll get two air conditioning make sure
don't put it on recycle put it on the
air that's coming in oh it's busted
anyway all right well maybe that's for
the better
[Music]
[Applause]
Saru bench I lost him holder right there
[Music]
[Applause]
why are you running I was I wouldn't run
I was I was relaxing I would have taken
a repose you were taking a repose oh
yeah that's all I was knowing you guys
think that I was running from you yes
you were running from us why are you
yeah no no no I okay let me try and may
I make it man make an inquiry you know
what I wish you would so I can catch my
breath okay hypothetically speaking yes
all right if you did indeed see me yes
are you sure that I was not running with
you behind me in the intention of
showing you a crime scene is that what
that your intention is exactly what I
was doing because they don't like you
were running from us we said freeze yeah
stop get on the ground get on the ground
and you didn't because you were leading
us quickly to a crime nothing if I
continued to run at the pace I was
running you guys would get there before
us and crime was perpetrated but you got
so far ahead of us that you thought
you'd take a rest so you jump - that's
my that's my 380 this is yours so you're
saying right now to me this is yours we
were chasing you I should put it down
put it down put it down and you threw it
right because I felt that the chase was
not spicy enough you know I felt like I
really needed you guys to step it up in
pursuit of me all those you're back to
the crime spicy enough for you I
literally my pants about a mile thick
then once again would you rather have me
in a pronated or a supinated position
you